Every technology I look at is now
entering this expedites will go.
Ray Kurzweil says,
is any technology.
It becomes
the information.
It starts advancing exponentially.
It seems that everything is being
digitized now and every technology I
look at seems to be entering this
exponential curve and what happens is
that when technology is advancing at an
exponential curves,
they're doing amazing things,
but when technologies converge,
when exponential technologies converge,
that's when you get industry
disruptions.
Behind everything is computing.
You know this device over here,
but my estimate is more powerful than 40
cray super computers were.
Remember cray super computers that we
used to cost in the tens of millions of
dollars that had export controls on
them.
This is more powerful than those cray
super computers where there's something
in computing called Moore's law,
but Moore's law stipulates that the
processing power of computers doubles
every year or two.
It's actually the number of transistors,
but what in fact happens is that the
power increases,
the cost drops and this size become
smaller.
This exponential curve they're computing
is on means that faster computers can
design faster computers with faster
computers.
You can now design new types of sensors
with faster computers.
You can now build artificial
intelligence with faster computers.
You can now analyze data like wouldn't
even never analyze before.
When you have artificial intelligence
and sensors and robotics coming
together,
you get R,
two,
d,
Two from from star wars.
You get these humanoid robots that can
do what human beings can do.
You get the ability now to have robots
that can stock your shelves,
that can operate machinery,
that can be receptionists in your
offices,
so you have multiple technologies coming
together,
which,
which make it possible to do things I
could never be done before.
If you look at drones,
what are drones?
We had flying machines for a long time,
but these flying machines we used to
build these toys.
We built this toy.
Helicopters weren't stable when you
added a dreamer shifts to them when you
added computing to them and you added
deliberative artificial,
artificial intelligence to them so they
could keep track of all the data around
them.
You had the ability to have these drones
being stable and now ship goods,
so drones are advancing almost
exponentially and those drones are gonna
disrupt the entire logistics industry.
Imagine now being able to have your mail
being delivered to your mailbox using
drone.
Imagine having packages being delivered
by drone.
Imagine having us being delivered by
drone.
I'm not kidding.
Look at a hung and what they're doing in
Dubai.
That's really a drone on steroids that's
being used to transport human beings.
So every industry I look at,
I see as being ready for major
disruption.
Manufacturing is going to come back to
the United States.
In fact,
it is coming back to the United States
right now because of robots that can do
what human beings can do.
You have financial.
It's about way disrupted because you
have robot advisors,
you have digital,
you now have data which kind of stock
trades and so on.
All of these advances happening,
which I'm about to just help finance and
when you look at transportation,
you have electric cars which are
becoming cheaper and cheaper because of
the advances in battery technologies.
You have self driving technologies
because of the advances in ai imagined
self driving electric cars that cost
about 15 or $20,000 in the year,
20,
25.
What do you think has been happening to
GM,
Ford,
Toyota,
all of these companies will still need
one or two electric companies,
but more likely than not,
there'll be some upstarts from silicon
valley or from New Delhi or from Sao
Paulo that put the right technologies
together and that are inexpensive,
that started disrupting the entire
transportation industry.
As soon we're going to have virtual
reality that's going to disrupt
education itself.
Imagine being able to put glasses on and
watch me watch this in three dimensions
and converse with me.
Imagine me able to meet with people
interactively on the moon,
on are on Mars or in Tahiti.
That's going to disrupt the entire,
uh,
conferencing industry because we will be
able to have meetings in exotic places
and it'll feel like we're almost there,
right?
Education.
Imagine being able to learn science by,
um,
by doing virtual experiments,
anatomy,
by seeing your human body inside and
out.
Imagine learning mathematics by going
into ancient Egypt.
And building permits,
imagine learning Latin by going back in
time and,
and talking to people in Latin.
I mean this is all becoming possible and
this is within five years we'll have
that.
Imagine having digital tutors that,
that monitor your expressions.
Cameras can already do that.
And then monitor the child's interest in
learning.
If the child likes to play games,
it plays games with them.
The child likes to play to watch videos.
It takes them into three dimensional
holographic worlds and lets them
experience,
um,
and have experiences and learn on their
own is the child likes reading books.
It reads books to them.
So we're talking about disrupting
education itself.
Now granted that the,
uh,
the harvards,
the Carnegie Mellon's,
you know,
the elite universities have several
brand name was still value them,
but the world's masters will be able to
now get into holographic words and learn
in many new ways.
Every single industry where technology
can be applied is about to be disrupted
in,
in a,
in a big way.
Let's look at our own health.
What's happening now is that we become
data and no doctor,
they've got mixed software.
Let me explain,
we were fitbit's,
we were all these devices that monitor
body's functioning,
move forward five years and will have
sensors in our clothing.
Imagine that fruit of the loom tag in
your underwear,
which is monitoring you,
24 slash seven,
monitoring your activity levels,
which is monitoring your ekg is all
these different symptoms that can be
captured from the skin.
Imagine it being gathered 24 slash seven
being uploaded to the cloud and having
an ai now analyzing the data and say,
look,
you're about to get sick.
You need to get some exercise,
and then having all of these cameras and
sensors which watch what we're eating,
what we're doing,
and saying,
alright Vivec,
you don't need that extra piece of Pie.
Stop,
abort,
abort.
This is all becoming possible in the
next five years or so,
we should be able to build these
technologies.
So we have digital doctors.
Now,
the second part of it,
genomics,
in the year 2000,
there was a race between the US
government and a scientist,
greg venter,
to sequence the human genome.
The government and affiliated lab spent
two point seven,
$5,000,000,000.
Venter came up with $100,000,000.
Don't ask cow,
but he took government data,
any sequence,
a human genome.
It made front page news worldwide.
For a long time.
Nothing happened.
We thought genomics was a waste of
money,
but over the last two or three years,
it's now gone at this exponential curve.
The study's been published very
frequently.
Now,
almost every week you're seeing
groundbreaking study is about the
discoveries,
discoveries in genomics,
the correlations between our health and
our genes,
but you know something.
What blows my mind the most is the
microbiome.
When you went to school,
your teacher,
your biology teacher taught you that
we've made up of cells and the cells
have a nucleus and that's where your DNA
is.
Do you know something?
What she taught you was wrong?
We made up of bacteria.
We have somewhere between two and 10
times more bacteria in our body than we
have cells.
The same technology which is sequenced.
They used to sequence the human body and
that's being used to sequence plants has
been sequenced.
It's been used to sequence the bacteria
in our gut and for the last few years
they had been measured breakthrough than
this.
Now I have a google alert on the word
microbiome.
Everyday I read new studies,
new breakthroughs happening with the
microbiome.
It seems that the DNA is important and
relevant,
but we may be looking under the wrong.
A lamp over here.
They also study which is showing that
it's what we eat and the,
uh,
this,
these trillions of bacteria that we have
in our,
in our body that there may be regulating
our health unit.
For example,
they will study.
There was a study published in nature
magazine about a year and a half ago in
we say took the,
uh,
the feces,
if I can say this on big thing.
Feces means shit to feces of a fat mouse
and gave it to 'em a 10 miles.
And the thin mouths gained weight.
They took the feces from a thin Muslin,
gave it to a fat mouse and the mouse
lost weight.
Now,
China is also replicated some of these
findings in human beings and they
determined that there's a correlation
between obesity and your microbiome,
so forget all these diets we've been
obsessed with.
Could it simply be a matter of taking
the feces of a thin person and giving it
to a fat person and a fat person loses
weight?
Let's watch this space over the next
five years.
We'll have scientific evidence of this
and also curing disease.
They've been studies to show the Crohn's
disease,
which is a debilitating disease that
children get.
They took the feces of a healthy child
and gave it to an unhealthy child and it
appears that the unhealthy child was
killed.
You're curing disease by transplanting
bacteria.
It doesn't make sense.
And then,
um,
antibiotics.
There have been several studies which
show that children who received
antibiotics than to be a base,
it may well be that antibiotics are
killing off entire species of bacteria
in our body and they're making us sick.
You know,
this is the crazy prediction.
And,
um,
but I really believe this is going to
happen that within 10 or 15 years we
look,
come to the conclusion that antibiotics
were destroying our health.
It may well be that we look at
antibiotics the same way we look at
those leeches that they use to suck out
blood from patients in,
in,
uh,
in England.
And you know,
the belief was that you could kill
health by sucking our blood using
leeches.
Okay.
That may be what antibiotics are doing
to us.
Still emerging technology.
We don't know yet,
but when I read these studies every day,
that is a conclusion I'm getting to that
the entire Western medical system is
about to be up ended through the
microbiome.
So move forward to the 20 20th.
We have all of these diagnostic data.
We have all of these data about our
genome and our microbiome.
We have data on not thousands of people
but hundreds of millions of people.
And we have ai that analyzes all of the
information.
That app on your smartphone that's
monitoring you.
Twenty four slash seven may be the best
doctor you've ever had.
It's your friend.
It's your advisor,
it guides you on how to maintain optimal
health and it guides you on how to get
healed.
If you do get sick,
this is five slash 10 maximum 15 years
from now,
I think closer to the five to 10 year,
a beard that will have all these amazing
advances.
So this is exponential.
It's incredible.
It's amazing.
And,
um,
what the future holds in health.
If you look at artificial intelligence,
I know when I was young I was reading
about how ai would soon be able to
defeat the humans at playing chess and
everything else.
They will,
all these predictions made in the 19
sixties about how ai will become smarter
than men.
And then in the 1980 then in 1990
nineties,
we heard about Japan and the fifth
generation project,
we sort of thought that Japan would rule
the world and an ai.
And then what happened?
Nothing happened.
We basically had what was called the
new,
the Ai winter that,
um,
uh,
there was a cloud cost over Ai.
We thought it was a hoax.
It was a fraudulent and ai was dead.
Isn't dead,
is everywhere.
Because here's,
here's what happened.
Scientists also started speculating on a
new method of doing ai.
The Ai that defeated Garry Kasparov,
big blue was really a decision tree.
It did,
if then l statements of every possible
chess move and with super fast
computers,
it was able to outsmart a human being
that's really simplifying the
technology,
but that's more or less the ai we had a
decade or 15 years ago and scientists
have speculated that maybe we could do a
different form of Ai.
We could mimic the human brain.
The human brain has layers of neurons
which you know,
and the connections between the neurons,
the program based on what's learned.
So a child sees a dog and mom says,
this is the doggy,
this is a cat and this and the neurons
adjust themselves to do associate that,
that image of,
you know,
an animal with the ears and a tail and
so on,
the shape with a dog.
So outbrain programs itself based on
what it learns.
So scientists speculated there were
papers published study years about this,
that we could do ai using neural
networks.
Here's what the problem was to do neural
We needed massively parallel computers.
We didn't have those,
even the fastest supercomputers of their
time in the 1970,
then the 19 eighties and even 19
nineties,
couldn't do massively parallel computing
about a decade ago and video and decided
to develop a chip to let children play
video games better.
The GPU,
the graphics processing unit and,
and uh,
they released it a few years ago.
It became a big success and then
scientists are looking at that Gpu and
realize that that's a massively parallel
computer.
Why can't we now do ai with it?
Started doing it and machine learning,
develop their many words over here,
but essentially we started mimicking the
human brain and using these,
these,
these GPS to learn the way human beings
do.
That's when you started having Elon Musk
and Stephen Hawking and a bunch of
others talking about artificial general
intelligence saying,
oh my God,
these things are going to be smarter
than us and all of these dangers.
The trouble was that that was the stuff
of science fiction and this was narrow
ai where you specifically taught a
computer what to learn.
You developed a model and then you throw
data at it and it learned from that.
So we assumed that you this age,
I was 20,
30 years away.
Here's what happened in the last couple
of weeks with a narrow,
narrow ai that a bunch of scientists
figured out how to defeat capture by
having the computer learn itself,
did experiments.
It really tried every combination,
figured it out.
And then Google was able to um,
to have alphago which is defeat these
goplayers at learned on its own.
So it seems like narrow ai is running on
its own now.
You can throw anything you want at it.
If you take that one step further and
you say,
okay,
I can learn anything that you wants to
learn and you'll begin to see out of
your general artificial general
intelligence,
the stuff out of science fiction
becoming possible.
So this is all happening a lot faster
than if anyone.
Anyone imagined.
I mean,
maybe there was some people who saw it
coming,
but the vast majority of experts in this
field didn't think that ai would
progress at the rate it's progress just
over the last few weeks and it could
well be that we get are today to a.
You Remember Star Wars Rosie from the
jetsons.
Samantha from her.
All of these things was found science
fiction that they starts showing up in
our apps and then in these bots we have
at home in the next seven to 10 years.
So I won't be surprised if I'm able to
order a rosy on Amazon.com in the year
20,
25,
27 and she's droned over to my house and
Rosie costs about $10,000 because that
is how ai and robotics and whole bunch
of other technologies are advancing
exponentially.
Ever since the Internet came out,
we've started ordering things on the
Internet with the first one is some of
the,
some of the earliest websites were
these,
uh,
these websites is retailing websites
where you could buy oddities on the,
on the Internet.
And then we could buy clothing on the
Internet and then you can buy shoes on
the Internet,
and now Amazon has become a dominant
player because practically everything
you need can be ordered on the Internet
and it comes to your house often within
an hour or so.
So that was retail disruption
one-on-one.
Now,
something even more dramatic is
happening that the retail store itself
is becoming digitized.
When you walk into your supermarket,
when you walk into any retail store,
you'll note that the camera's over
there,
you know the last two years or so,
the ability for computers to recognize
faces,
exceeded the ability of human beings to
do recognize faces.
So those cameras now had the ability to
know who you are.
And they have the ability now to just do
a interface with the registers where you
buy things and to keep track of what are
you but your bought.
Give it five or 10 years and you'll be
walking up to the counters and you'll
have.
You'll have ads being served to you
based on your buying habits and based on
your interests.
So the entire retail experience begins
to change because you have customized
coupons,
customized ads all being served 50
years.
You walk in there,
but then also the sensors I talked about
the cameras,
they can also detect inventory.
They can see what's on the shelf,
how much of it has been sold.
You don't until today we we've had human
beings going and doing an inventory
checks every two or three days ago and
see what needs to be stacked and so on.
But with this cameras they can keep
track of what's on the shelves and they
can automatically order.
New replenishment is as needed and then
we'll have robots that can go and
replenish the shelves rather than human
beings going in and stalking.
You know,
I'll sell boxes.
Imagine you had robots that can do that
already.
The number of robotic technologies that
can.
They can go in and do this thing,
but give it five or seven years we'll
have robots replenishing shelves,
will have sensors and ai monitoring
inventory move forward a couple of
years.
Virtual reality is going to become much
more powerful.
Imagine wearing eyeglasses that dundalk
and take you into a holographic worlds.
Imagine now being able to meet people
where they want to and being able to
converse with them as if you were there.
Imagine not being able to go into a
store and now pick and choose what you
want from it.
Being able to examine the merchandise
and just say,
okay,
I'll take it and imagine having a drone
over to your house.
Let me switch gears now and talk about
saving the world because I live in
Silicon Valley and frankly I get
depressed at the fact that the tens of
billions of dollars being thrown at
mindless apps,
they would happen to.
There's some kid comes up with some new
stupid APP and he gets $100,
million in funding and other vcs give to
another hundred million dollars a
competitive it is.
We basically chasing rainbows in silicon
valley and not understanding the
problems of the world.
I was born in India.
I traveled the world and when I go
there,
I see poverty.
I see despair.
I see,
uh,
you know,
people living in ill health.
I see hunger,
I see disease,
I see you know,
a majority.
I see people getting sick because of bad
water and it's depressing to see that we
are living in silicon valley.
We're blessed living in New York City.
You're blessed because you have
everything you need.
We don't.
We know we see poverty and we ignore it,
but by and large,
we're not sensitive to the needs of the
world.
You travel to the developing world.
You see the dire poverty and the pain
and suffering,
but you know something I believed in the
next 10 or 15 years we can solve
virtually all of these problems that
are,
that are,
you know,
hurting people so much.
You know,
the,
the biggest volume is energy.
When people in remote parts of India,
Africa,
South America come home,
they can't study because they don't have
light.
This is something we can't comprehend in
America that you don't have lights.
You can study.
Therefore children don't get education,
but this is a common problem in the
developing world.
80 eight percent of the infections
disease in the developing world is
caused by water borne viruses.
You know,
when you went to school,
you learned how to distilled water,
what do you do,
your body did you capture the
condensation and that is the distilled
water.
Distilled water is 100 percent pure.
There's nothing living in it right now.
All it takes to have 100 percent clean
water to boil the oceans and have all
the water we need is energy.
The trouble is it energy has been so
expensive.
Well,
guess what?
That's changing.
We're headed into an era of unlimited
clean and almost free energy.
Here's what's happening.
Solar Wind,
take solar as an example.
The cost of solar has dropped 99 percent
since 1976.
And what happens is that as the price
drops,
the installations installations double
as the is double the price drops.
We're in a virtuous cycle of here of,
of exponential technology advances at
the pace we're going.
We're only about six doublings away from
having the capability of generating 100
percent of the earth's energy needs
through solar.
This sounds crazy,
and the dumplings are happening less
than every two years from now.
So what I'm saying is that by 20,
30 or so,
we could have unlimited clean energy on
this planet from sunlight and the cost
will be a fraction of what it is today.
Imagine one 16th of what it is today,
one 30th of what it is today in less
than 15 years from now.
This seems crazy.
That seems unimaginable,
but all you have to do is look at the
data and look at the trend.
It is as clear as can be now in America,
we regressing because you now have the
US government.
And when I say US government,
I mean Donald Trump talking about
bringing coal back.
He's talking about stopping the progress
of solar energy because it disrupts us
unemployment.
This is complete nonsense.
Mean solar is generating more jobs than
coal ever had.
And uh,
this is good for America.
It's good for the world.
But regardless,
leave America site America is not
relevant anymore.
The really good news that we hear is
that America isn't leading the world
anymore.
It's China.
Number one.
They have committed to me,
I think 200 gigawatts in the next five
or seven years in India.
Number two,
they talk about 100 gigawatts.
We're talking about,
you know,
the two largest population countries in
the world now leading the bath on solar
and even America decides to bring coal
back instead of coal fire plants.
It doesn't matter the world.
World War simple,
laugh at us.
The cost of solar will still still
advanced and the beauty of this is that
every village in the world will now have
light.
Now,
the,
the challenge over here is that you need
to store the energy because it doesn't.
The Sun doesn't shine and when it's not
sunny,
the wind doesn't blow and it's windy,
but the,
the good thing is that the cost of
storage is also dropping exponentially.
We should talk about three,
four or $500 a kilowatt hour for
storage.
Elon musk is hinting at $100 a kilowatt
hour the next three or four years and it
could go to $70 a kilowatt hour.
When you talk about prices such as that,
you're talking about self driving
electric cars called costing about 15,
$20,000.
Being able to drive 200 miles by the mid
20,
20 is 20,
25.
We could have cars that cost $1,500 and
go 100,
200 miles.
We're talking about now having enough
storage for village for a couple of
thousand dollars,
which means that you could have entire
villages,
entire towns all over the world which
are off the grid and have unlimited
clean energy,
so now we can have unlimited clean water
because we could just boil the oceans.
We can now have lights that children can
come home and study and we can educate
them because they'll also have
smartphones that provided them with
knowledge.
We can now have diagnostic devices which
provide them with information so that
they can get into the smartphone and get
health.
They can grow,
have vertical farms.
This is another amazing technology that
we don't talk very much about in the
United States,
but vertical farming is now advancing
exponentially because of two or three
different convergences.
First of all,
led lighting.
We don't have to understand that led
lighting now has become cost about the
same as,
as these old bugs we had the edison
bulbs in the developing world.
They even cheaper and led lighting the,
there was a Nobel prize two years ago
for led lighting.
They've been such amazing breakthroughs
in led lighting so that you can now
fueling the,
um,
the frequencies to the growth of plants
so you can now have inexpensive energy
led lights and now you can also have
sensors and sensors,
cameras and other devices which monitor
crop growth,
which monitor the growth of every plant,
give them exactly the right nutrients,
glass houses.
We were talking about organic food.
We will be able to grow almost unlimited
food because of these advances in energy
led lighting,
ai and sensors.
That's in the next five or 10 years.
So we could literally have a planet
that's abundant in energy and food that
has perfect health in which we can three
d print our clothing.
All of these things are within reach
now that make get to the dark side of
all this.
And I talked about the advances in ai
and robotics and sensors,
industry disruptions,
despite what the optimists say,
despite what Silicon Valley says,
I don't see a scenario in which we'll
have enough jobs for human beings that
yes,
it will be new jobs graded zoomed by.
Don says,
and God knows what.
That's a stupid example.
Is that a tech mogul to throw up about
the new jobs that'll be created?
The fact is that these uber drivers,
these taxi drivers in New York City,
the even the uber drivers that we have
here now,
when the jobs get displaced,
they aren't going to be new jobs for
them.
The truck drivers,
you're talking about 3 million truck
drivers in the United States when we
have self driving trucks,
which is very likely in the next five
years or so.
Those Middle East truck drivers who
don't have other skills and driving are
not going to be able to learn how to
program robots or how to do Zumba
dancing.
Those truck drivers will be unemployed.
We're talking about people whose
livelihood depends on jobs.
Whose social stature depends on jobs.
I mean,
you know,
I think about it when we meet other
almost the first question we ask is what
do you do?
We're defined by our jobs and we take
pride in creativity and in our work and
our lives revolve around our work.
What happens when work disappears?
Even if you have all the energy you
want,
all the food you want,
you have perfect health,
you have all the things that you need.
You're able to three d print your,
your food and clothing and all that.
If you have all of those things taken
care of,
you have nothing to do.
You feel depressed.
What's the new social structure over
here?
What did we do with ourselves?
So silicon valley talks about universal
basic income.
That's their excuse for saying it's
someone else's problem.
It will be okay.
Let us get filthy rich and let someone
else worry about the problem.
We can just give money to everyone.
No people just don't want.
Many people want a purpose in life.
They want to be contributing to society.
They want to be doing good.
They wanted to be be earning their keep.
They don't want free money next,
you know,
10,
15 years.
I worry about him even as soon as five
years,
I worry about millions of people,
10 tens and millions of big people
becoming unemployed,
becoming depressed,
and I'm really rebelling that,
you know,
go back to the luddite movement.
So try to stop the progress of
technology because their livelihoods are
being taken away.
I worry about his dog scenario.
I worry about them wanting to burn down
the,
uh,
the tech companies and to stop progress
at all costs because their jobs are
being taken away.
Strikes just like you've had strikes in
Paris,
you taxi drivers trying to burn down.
Uber's,
I'm exaggerating a little bit,
but it turned to stop Uber's.
You may have that in New York City.
You may have a people whose lives have
been displaced.
You met people who have lost their
livelihood,
is now getting angrier and protesting.
Look what's happening in DC.
We have a government that's pandering to
the extremist groups to the anger,
right?
I mean,
it was unimaginable even two years ago
that we will be accusing the White House
of being Nazi sympathizers mean.
This is craziness.
I mean the allegations are not founded,
but the fact that we can even make those
allegations shows that something is
wrong over here,
that,
um,
the,
the gap between the haves and the have
nots has grown not only in money which
is always talk about before,
but also in knowledge,
in culture,
in values.
We're technical people who are watching
this or technology literate that you get
your information online,
you watch videos such as this and you
stay up to date with this.
The people in Middle America,
the truck drivers,
the taxi drivers,
many of them don't watch this and
they're not up to date.
We're doing nothing to mitigate the gap.
There are policymakers are talking about
taking things away,
taking healthcare away from people,
taking benefits away from people.
They're not talking about how do we now
uplift all of mankind.
They,
they think we have limited resources and
we have to ration them,
but they don't seem to realize that we
heard it edited to an era of abundance
in which we can now distribute the
perspective of grading and uplift all of
mankind.
In my book,
the driver and the driver of scar.
I tried to look at technology through
three lenses and the purpose of this was
to figure out how we can create the
amazing future star trek versus the
darkness of Mad Max.
The three lenses are,
number one,
does the technology have the potential
to benefit everyone equally?
Can we make sure that everyone gets good
healthcare from it?
Can we make sure that everyone gets
clean energy from it?
Can we make sure that everyone benefits
from the technology so that we don't
have people being left out and we don't
have anger brewing and then go back to
movies such as war of the worlds.
Go back to a lot of these science
fiction horror movies in these movies.
The rich had access to better technology
that they had health,
they had all sorts of good things that
pull had nothing.
They were working in the mines.
The outcome was always the same in all
of these movies that the war ended up
killing the rich madmax that the anger
started brewing and rebellion started
and the focus was to destroy the
technology to do,
do,
to kill the rich.
Basically,
this is what happens in all of these
dark movies.
If we don't know,
start educating and uplifting everyone
within had mad max.
The second lens is,
do the rewards outweigh the risks?
Is this technology going to benefit us
or is it going to hurt us?
We have to look at every technology to
make sure that the rewards outweigh the
risks.
For example,
gene editing Crispr,
we now have the ability to alter life
itself.
In about a decade from now,
we will have the ability to select the,
the,
uh,
um,
the feature that our children have.
This sounds crazy,
but we may be able to take pills that
alter the genome of an embryo and give
them new characteristics due to remove
disease and to give them maybe extra Iq.
This is all becoming possible.
Another question that if you do that,
do not create the um,
uh,
the world of Gatica,
that movie Gattica in which you had,
you know,
people who have enhanced and then you
had people who want enhanced and the
people that were unanswered.
It's basically based on society and
guess what,
the people who want enhanced rebelled or
we now creating super human beings.
Are we not creating killer viruses?
I will now creating massive joblessness
and we're now creating all of these new
nightmares with technologies.
Do the rewards truly outweigh the risks?
And then the question is,
does the technology great autonomy or
dependence?
I mean,
I'm a big fan of self driving cars.
I drive a tesla model s and I can't wait
to get into auto drive when I get on the
highway because I want the car to drive
itself.
Now eventually when I say eventually,
probably 10,
15 years from now,
we're going to be deciding that we don't
want these dangerous human beings on the
road is human beings get distracted.
They text while they're driving,
they get angry,
they get road rage.
The Russian,
the traffic at the same time,
they crash into each other.
They're dangerous.
We don't want these dangerous animals on
our roads.
Instead,
we want to have smart ai and robots
doing the driving,
so we made it through the human beings
off the road,
which means that we've lost autonomy,
right?
We get angry.
Gone are the tilt of driving,
so on the one hand,
self driving cars give us autonomy.
Why autonomy?
Because everyone now can get familiar
anyway.
They wanted to be where they want to be
safely.
Mothers can send their children to
school knowing that they will safely
arrived there,
the that blind to people who are
handicapped.
The old don't have to worry about having
to drive anymore.
We have autonomy like we've never had
before because it's not driving cars,
but then we lose another autonomy.
That autonomy is the right of being able
to drive on highways.
So you have a trade off over here.
The question is,
does it lead to.
Does technology to independence or
autonomy?
In the case of self driving cars,
it's both dependents and autonomy at the
same time,
but we've got to figure this out.
We've got to figure out what the
tradeoffs are.
So what I posit in driver in the
driverless car is that we have to look
at each technology technology through
this.
These three lenses,
and what I believe,
but I sincerely believe is that if we
get these right,
that if we now benefit everyone and we
do things in a sensible way,
we can create the amazing future of Star
Trek that we really can get to this
world in which we're now sharing
prosperity.
We're seeking enlightenment and others
were working to uplift humanity.
And we can do this 300 years old
schedule.